[Music]
you all found out that uh there's labor
shortages out there right
y'all found out that there's disruption
in supply chains right
um y'all found out that the irs went
completely bonkers and just quit working
all together during the pandemic like
for two years right
so here's the deal
weird tax seasons for the last couple of
years you bet the irs at this moment is
sitting on 20 million
tax returns
that have are unprocessed
so you used to file your taxes and you
know like a couple days later you would
get a refund
some of you have been waiting on a
refund for as much as 10 months now
yeah
so your little refund program's not
working for you which brings us to the
subject that refunds
are not
free money
they're not a gift from washington dc
i know santa claus personally i'm old
he does not live in dc
he lives in the north pole
you are not getting a gift from your
government when you get a refund
it is you have paid in too much
and there's a lot of money going in
rachel a lot well 75 percent of
taxpayers
got a refund on average of 2800 so yeah
when you get almost a three thousand
dollar check in the mail
it's like oh that's fun like you don't
even like there's gonna there obviously
is a reaction that happens
but the important thing there is
remembering like that's your money that
could have been three thousand dollars
over the course of a year
to be paying off debt or to save or to
use it to give or to spend even on what
you want like it was to be used for your
life and instead yeah like you're saying
channel my inner john deloney whoa are
you gonna be therapist dave right now no
we need to reframe
this that's what it says
i need to reframe your way of looking at
this you need to reframe the approach
you're taking to this so when you open a
the next time because of listening to
this piece of radio right now this piece
of this podcast right now the next time
you open your mailbox and there's a
refund i don't want you to go
i want you to go god i'm stupid
that is not john deloney
if you do stupid long enough you're just
stupid so but the uh oh my gosh so not
really 75
of the people listening are getting a
tax refund which means you paid too much
in taxes
without any interest they send it back
to you when they decide to finally go
back to work
and then you act like santa claus sent
you the money
no
that's not where it came from
so tax refund bad
not good okay here's a question
obviously the ideal is to get to zero
is where you don't owe any and you're
not getting that correctly but but
getting to that exact zero can be
difficult right especially in the last
year we've had people are taking on side
like i mean it's just everything's a
little bit wonky still would you rather
someone owe
a little bit and have money in savings
that they pay
or would you rather a tax refund happen
well i mean i want to get it down in the
100 range one way or the other
and it's difficult but it requires a
little effort but the first step of that
effort is to reframe the argument and go
tax refund stupid not good okay so now
once we get that reframing done we go
i've loaned the government money and
they paid me no interest and then they
gave it back to me when by god they
decided to finally come back to work
and so
you know
so and 75 percent of you got three
thousand dollars that's 250 a month
and you have a tight budget and you're
whining about gas prices and you're
worried about the cream cheese at publix
right rachel yeah so hey that fourth pig
resonated that's all i gotta say
fourth pig was popular i gotta say you
you you're a nerve with the fourth pig
don't get off track let's stay on focus
because we talked about that a while ago
so
twenty eight hundred dollars that's 250
a month too much coming out of your
taxes how do you adjust for that there's
two ways to do it
one is the simplest easy way is if
nothing has changed in your life you are
still in the same tax brackets you
haven't had a baby you didn't start us
out as well something's not different
from last year
then just adjust your withholding by 250
bucks because you're probably getting
exactly the same thing back so just
adjust it by that amount just go into
payroll and go i get 250 if your average
was 2800 if you're if you had a 3 000
refund that's 250 a month okay if you
had a 4 800 refund that'd be 400 a month
adjust it to where you get no refund now
if something's changed then what you do
is you jump in and just do a tax return
and act like what's going on and then
you can predict what your taxes are and
then make sure that amount is being
withheld check out one of our endorsed
local providers and uh they can help you
with this we've got ramsey trusted tax
pros if you have a com if you have a
complicated
return um and of course you also can get
ramsey smart tax
and if you're ramsey plus member ramsey
smart tax online filing is free so you
can actually run through the scenario
and figure out what it is you're going
to owe and you go okay i owe
i don't know make up a number 12 000
okay well that's a thousand dollars a
month should be coming out of your check
not
1250
and so your goal is to zero this out and
don't end up owing more than has been
withheld it's not that you owe taxes
because you already did owe taxes they
just took out
so when you come up when you come up
short and you're gonna have to write a
check at tax time that doesn't mean you
owe taxes you already owed taxes you
just owe a little bit more
taxes that you haven't yet paid that's
all it is okay isn't that owing taxes no
huh isn't that owing
it's not you already owe the taxes yeah
that hasn't changed sure
it's just the fact you under withheld
and so you have to pay a little bit more
that's right that's right so you owed 12
000 and you only sent in uh 11
950. so
when you pay 50 it's not i owe 50 in
taxes no you've just underpaid your
taxes
by sure you're 12 000 in taxes by 50 yes
so don't don't get confused because the
biggest scam of all times
from
uh uh from a standpoint of of
uh
you know basically conning the public
was when they passed the law that
allowed taxes to be withheld from your
paycheck so you the taxes come out
before you ever see it
if people actually had to write a check
or go down with cash to a location and
take the money in 100 bills every week
to the tax collector
at a location there would be a
revolution in america because people
would realize how much their freaking
taxes are and the tax collector would be
looked at as a scumburger like he was in
biblical times
but the fact that it just comes out of
your check and you never see it it's
it's lulled the sheeple to sleep
and the sheeple all just pay taxes out
their freaking ears
and nobody raises a flag and goes you
people are buying 250 000 toilet seats
with this money you're taking out of my
check up there you guys are a bunch of
island of misfit toys you need to stop
it but if you actually had to go pay 100
bills or change everything so anyway
that's a great point so go to
ramseysolutions.com and get ramsey smart
tax it's the online filing it'll make it
easier for you less painful and if you
really have got a complicated return
like you've got the side hustle you've
picked up some other deductions you
don't know what to do with them it's
worth the money to get a pro on your
side to help you do at a ramsey trusted
pro at ramseysolutions.com one of our
tax
elps but address the issue
pay attention and reframe the argument
would you open the envelope don't go tax
refund good go tax refund stupid you
need to reframe that in your head and
not act like a celebration is happening
here instead it should be an act of
shame and guilt and condemnation
i'm kidding but
rachel you're so sensitive i know
don't put me in that camp i'm a realist
is what i am
well i just want you walking from the
mailbox with your head down instead of
dancing no i agree i'm there yes yes
that's all i'm saying